[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
what lad well it's not every day you get
one of the greats on the podcast but
today is one of those days as a genuine
legend joins me for this one he's played
for auckland he's played for the blues
and of course he's won two rugby world
cups with the all blacks and he's widely
regarded as one of the greatest loose
forwards in all black history he's also
had a stint in japan with two out of her
blitz and he's recently retired from
rugby after helping to lose win the
champions cup in the top 14 double but
above all the wins in accolades he's an
absolute lad who's had a massive impact
on so many guys careers it is of course
the one and only jerome kino welcome
brother hey brother thanks for having me
on man my absolute privilege to have a
legend on like yourself and it's been a
massive morning for the marshall
household we just opened the wheat bix
box and the boys pull out the jerome
kind of legends card what a morning
oh awesome
how does it feel to be put on that sort
of list with i think there's only like
10 sort of guys and you're one of the
the legends that i guess sanitarium have
chosen to be one of the greatest all
blacks of all time
and it's pretty cool um
yeah i just uh i saw the sky tv or sky
sports uh
uh greatest all black side and um you
know there's some legends on that side
but that's even here my name uh he's
spoken in the same sentence as the likes
of richard mccor and
michael jones to michael jones it's uh
it's quite humbling but um yeah to to be
having to be able to play one test for
the all blacks was a
was a dream come true but uh to be in
there for as long as i it was uh
it was incredible mate how good is that
and so
the boots are all hung up now are you
getting at your feet the season started
you're wishing you're back still back
out there playing or you had enough
absolutely not man um
rocking up with the coaching staff for
pre-season and seeing the current sit
out for the bronco
yeah
did not get at your feet it was quite
enjoy enjoyable just sitting there and
watching the boys do the the hard guards
pre-season
how is your body now
oh it's feeling pretty good i i do get
the odd aches and the joints every now
and then from being
a bit inactive
but um
with the staff and all of the players
still being in the gym it gives me a bit
of a
incentive to get out there and and uh do
a better exercise every now and then but
um
i guess that's the that's the drive at
the moment to try not to to go for as
long and not not do any exercise
yeah have you found it hard to stay
motivated to exercise i know i've
personally found that really hard well i
kind of enjoyed it
for the first
seven weeks seven eight weeks just to
not do anything but
when you get up and you get uh
you're aching back and the knees are
starting to i'm doing nothing
yeah you kind of have to find that
motivation to get out there and try and
stay active just to keep away the aches
and pains
far fair enough and so you've
transitioned pretty seamlessly into
coaching nowadays so i've got to lose
off to a hissing start three from three
so mate you're doing something right
there oh man it's uh i'm i'm in the
learning phase learning process uh
trying to get my head around
the structures and how how to how the
coaches
do things so
for me it
for the next few months or so at least
is just to try and find my
position or my my groove within the
coaching staff and it's it's been
awesome i'm learning lots every day and
off the players and stuff but
it's it's not from many of my doing that
the boys have uh
got off to a really good start i i think
that um having the core players
return back in good shape and
and still having those combinations
together from last year it's really
helped us a lot
and it's a testament to the coaching
stuff as well who've
tried to
adapt things and change the way we play
so that would don't come too predictable
but
touch wood hopefully the the momentum
and the
and the mojo continues
mate you guys have a really talented
squad there right yeah oh
we we speak about golden ages of certain
countries and i think uh france french
rugby are
entering through their their golden spot
they've got some
awesome talent a lot of depth in certain
positions but um
definitely their key players uh
some of the best in the world
to name a few roman intermac and anton
dupont who were quite lucky to have a
now squad and
though these guys are like 22 23 24 and
um
the way they play and the way they hold
themselves it's uh it's incredible and
they're going to be
on the international stage for years to
come now which is uh
just good to uh sit back and watch
and you've got a few good kiwi boys with
you over there as well too haven't you
yeah
we got peter ki joe takori charlie from
winner um
tim nanowilliams just joined our our
squad this year which is uh
which is awesome and we've got a lot of
great uh younger players as well but
uh
those those first few that i named uh
i think they were the the backbone of
our our team last year i think peter
aqui should have been the
or would have been our the player of the
tournament uh top 14 last year
it was incredible for us and
um
the way he's been playing and uh and
will continue to do this year but um
it's just incredible how
the team have been able to jail together
um and and put up the performances and
have the year that we had last year was
uh it was awesome yeah that's awesome to
hear peter keys carving it up over there
he's come a long way from us put a pit
sponsorship at the hurricanes where
i know he suffered a lot of injury with
injuries when he was here in new zealand
so it's me it's awesome seeing him um
living up to his potential because he
was always a really talented player yeah
i was lucky to spend a few years with
him at the blues when i came back from
japan and
he was always uh
like an incredible player had the x
factor just uh
the injuries that he was unlucky to have
and
which is uh awesome to see here in
france he's been able to manage through
some niggles but uh
it's really important for our our team
and our club that he's always out there
and last year he was always out there
putting out the performances and
um
yeah definitely been um
one to watch for the last few years
and was coaching always the transition
you wanted to get into is that what you
always wanted to do after rugby was that
the plan it wasn't at the top of my list
uh like for me i never really wanted to
just fall into coaching because it was
uh
it's all i know yeah like i've been and
rugby for
so many years and i always wanted to
explore other things but
with the way the world's been panning
out the last couple of years and um
also returning back home uh
seemed a bit of a headache um
for me and my family
uh the opportunity came up uh when we
were reassessing what was gonna happen
the next few years and the club
approached me about uh
staying on and and uh
trying out coaching and also working
with the academy here uh for me it was
it was awesome i always wanted to get
back home and either work with uh
schools or within rugby and uh the
community and this fell right into what
i wanted to do so
um
instead of
creating a head-up headache for
ourselves and shipping everything back
home while the world's
the way it is
make more sense to to settle the kids in
for the next few years and
learn a different language learn
different culture and experience this
world where well while we can and how
the family finding it over there do they
love the french lifestyle well the kids
love it uh they're in a great they're in
great schools great friends around and
and like you said we've got a
great group of
expats foreigners here which which helps
a lot
they're really enjoying learning french
and
my daughter's
got a lot of spanish friends as well and
and she's learning spanish which is
which is awesome she's
learning at a faster pace than uh than i
am but uh no the the family enjoying it
which made my decision to to take up the
role um a lot easier yeah that's cool so
how is your friends do you have to speak
french now that you're a coach or you
just speak
english with the translator oh i'm i'm
really pushing to try and uh
become as fluent as i can i can
understand majority of the
conversations and uh what whatever i'm
saying it's just a matter of putting my
my sentences together and and having the
confidence to reply but
where i'm at at the moment it's it's uh
probably 80 english and 20 french which
isn't good enough for the amount of time
i've been here but um
it's a tough language to pick up and to
try and speak button i'm really enjoying
the process to try and try and learn and
and
become as fluent as i
i should be as a coach can you can you
speak someone yeah yeah you can speak
someone fluently true and how did you go
and with japanese when you're in japan
so you've you've obviously got a little
bit of all these languages in your head
yeah well i found japanese a lot easier
than uh french
the vowels are similar to samoan and
maori
and in most
cases one word would mean one thing in
a certain context we're here in france
uh one word can change from past tense
uh present tense feminine masculine and
uh yeah it gets a
pretty complicated uh trying to
structure your sentences but uh i guess
that's the the fun of uh trying to learn
a different language hundred percent
anyway mate obviously a massively
successful career so i'm pretty keen to
hear it from the start what what was it
like for you um growing up in auckland
man it was cool um
now growing up in papakura we uh
i had a group of friends where we would
always play touch after school at the
local park and
um man i tried to do all sorts of sports
volleyball basketball athletics um
you name it we did it and
it's uh it was just a normal uh classic
huey kid uh
upbringing where where
you'd always be active
but um no i loved it and um
my i think my first love was either
athletics or rugby league because uh
my household would always be glued to
the tv on friday nights watching other
canberra raiders or
or the manatee eagles which were my um
favorite teams growing up
and uh it was always rugby league uh
wasn't until the test matches all black
test matches were on that twin would
watch rugby but uh rugby league was the
first uh a game i always uh wanted to
watch and always watched
um it wasn't until uh
later in high school when all my mates
would be playing uh either first 15 or
under 16's rugby
which uh made me uh want to make the
switch just just so i could play with my
mates true you must have been uh
dominant at a young age where you would
have just been bigger stronger faster
than everyone where you would have you
would have been a nightmare to play
against as a kid i'd imagine
no i um i played in the back
earlier on i was a fullback center uh
the old timer first five but i was
useless at kicking i couldn't
i was really fast
but um it wasn't until my second to last
year of high school when i got a
scholarship to sing kent's
um when my coach tim connolly at the
time uh mentioned uh
you should try at least forward you're
getting a bit big and started to fill
out and i tried it and stayed there ever
since all right so i'm
quite thankful for my first thing coach
to
to offer me the
the position to switch and uh man i
loved it ever since and you had a stack
team at st kent said yeah too didn't you
weren't you playing with rocket foco and
john arfola obviously yourself yeah all
getting paid big bucks
is the rumor we need to squash this way
you know this question came in a few
times
i'm sure it's all those awkward grammar
kings college haters that
said we were getting paid but uh no we
were we're all quite lucky to to move up
to st camps at the same time from south
auckland and
yeah we had some awesome players uh
at that time and um
i was very lucky to get that opportunity
because um uh my focus at school at
papakura wasn't really uh the best but
uh
i think the switch to thinking came at
the right time to focus on school work
and also
uh give rugby a decent decent nudge were
you thinking rugby as a job at this time
no no no it was uh
it wasn't really in my head to give it
girls more
focused around schoolwork and and to
focus and rugby was also part of it uh
to to make sure that i i could give it a
good go if it was going to work for me
or not
but um no it wasn't on the radar to
become a professional rugby player or
even uh play npc at that time
because i still wasn't too sure if i was
even uh
made up for for rugby because i was
still either playing in the backs or
just moving into the forwards and yeah
still trying to find my spot
but to 100 we weren't getting paid to go
to school
let me see that person
but anyway you obviously were a talented
player and then you ended up making the
new zealand cults you became the pl
you're the player of the tournament when
you went away to the rugby world cup so
you progressed through the ranks pretty
quickly er
yeah it was uh
i was quite lucky straight out of school
i um
i spent uh two years with uh titch
at his training camps and uh
doing those infamous uh training camps
out in palmerston north which
that was how but uh for me as a young
kid just trying to
know what it takes to
i learned work ethic and
what it needed what i needed to have to
be a professional rugby player and
jesus wasn't easy um i spent two years
in
in his system and never got a
never got a tournament true was that
just because of fitness because i know
willis halaholo mentioned that he beat
your beep test record for the worst ever
oh yeah
it's probably hard to beat my my big
test record uh no he was worse he got
the worst one
yeah
man it was how we would do uh
like 150s uh the phosphate test and then
uh 15 minute break and then you go to
the beep test and i was wrecked by the
time we were warming up
with a big test so there was there
wasn't much of a score there to
to brag about but
yeah it was uh
those were some tough uh
dark days
spending with touch and
and working there but um no i really
enjoyed it
coming out of that uh moving into 15s i
i felt like i was quite prepared to
and and fit enough to to give it a good
go and i'll start it still at a young
age um at that time which was uh which
was awesome what was that sevens
environment like work because there
would have been some
uh pretty big dog sevens players back
then were they were they all really good
to you coming in there as a you must
have been what 18 19. yeah no it was an
awesome setup um
a great bunch of guys in uh like the
siemens environment it's it's quite uh
it's quite unique and they have their
own little um
little things or ways that they
they make it unique to other new zealand
teams but uh at that time there was
it koka tafayowasa orini
uh liam misum and tamira latimer were
starring in those teams as well
so um mate just eric rush as well that's
right so
much muscle valance so to be training
with those guys uh
most weekends was uh it was incredible
um
um just seeing how they went about their
work and what they needed to do to to be
the best because they were winning
back-to-back uh
world series
at that time and uh it was just
incredible to be in and around that
environment did that give you the
confidence in yourself that when you
went to this under 21 world cup that you
were ready and you you were definitely
good enough yeah of course um when you
when you're in
coaches uh touch
pitches system um
you knew that uh
what you were doing in those sessions
and what you were doing around the
environment no one else was working as
hard as you were
and you could guarantee that the way
the boys were
training and uh and working so for me
moving out of that and going into the
hundred twenty ones under nineteen to
under twenty ones
and even the auckland system i knew that
i was prepared well enough to to
give whatever team it was to give it a
good crack and to be the best i could be
in those environments so
yeah leaving the ceilings it kind of
prepared me for anything pretty much and
uh
which
gave me that confidence to just go out
there and express myself because i know
i've done the work and when you'd won
all these awards like play of the year i
think you won the new zealand junior
player of the year or something as well
did that give you more confidence or did
that
add pressure did you start feeling the
expectation was on you to
um succeed in footy
oh
i'd say it gave me confidence but uh
yeah like you said on the other hand it
did add a bit of pressure because you're
still young and then you're moving into
uh
15 inside rugby where a lot of guys are
established but uh your name's been
bandied around um
as being the next best thing and you
know that those guys are looking at you
looking to to prove a point so yeah it
did add a bit of pressure to go out
there and perform but um
i was young enough and i i don't think i
really care too much about pressure i
just wanted to get out there and get my
chance to to prove myself
and you did that pretty much straight
away for the auckland side i
um made an instant impact in there well
i was uh
i think that first year for me just uh
training alongside carlos spencer and
guys i used to have on a poster on my
wall a couple of years before
being in and around that environment uh
man i think i spent the first year just
uh
pinching myself in but uh
just not being able to believe that i'm
training with these guys and uh rocking
up to meetings with them and
it was uh it was pretty surreal it was
cool um
i speak to my dad about all the time we
used to get the
the auckland or blues posters out of the
herald uh
every year and um i used to always put
it up on the in the hallway at home and
and to be running out and training with
them and even doing that poster shoot
with them i used to tell them that
geez i used to watch you guys on uh i
used to stare at their poster all the
time and and now i'm here doing with you
guys
that was crazy and i'm sure a lot of
guys go through that
similar memory but uh for me it was uh
it was incredible
and what were the guys like when you
went into the environment because one
thing that's probably come up a few
times throughout this podcast is how
good you've been for young guys who have
come into the all blacks or coming to
the auckland environment making them
feel comfortable so yeah did someone do
this to you when you went in or did you
have the opposite where you felt like
you needed to maybe um make more of an
effort in that space yeah i i think i
had to make more of an effort when i was
in that uh
when i first came in because there are a
lot of older
older established all blacks in there in
case muse carlos spencer and
i think lee stensonis was still playing
at that time but
um
i i had kevin melamu and
irani clark who were there at the time
as well they
[Music]
they took me in and always made me
comfortable wherever i was
being a young guy i was like a deer in
headlights always wondering when the
next meeting is if i'm going to miss
a training time and
yeah i was always reassured by those
guys and
and um
to make sure that i just be myself and
uh
yeah going through going through those
uh periods i always made sure that when
i
when i'm a senior player and i either
get the chance to
to take the younger guy under my wing
then i want to make sure that they're as
comfortable as they can just to
express themselves because
you you'd see it you'd see some young
kids come in and kind of keep to
themselves and
you're not too sure whether they're
comfortable enough to
fully fully uh
express themselves wherever they are so
i just wanted to make kids or younger
guys comfortable enough to be able to
say oh
i'm just going to be me and not worry
about anything else it's so cool because
it makes a massive difference and it
doesn't take much for for you as a
senior player to make someone feel
comfortable you just have to go up and
maybe say a word or something but it can
have a massive impact on some of these
young guys
careers oh
yeah exactly but then the all blacks the
same year so one year in the auckland
item or mpc side you're saying you're
still feeling like a deer in the
headlights and just cooled straight into
the all black team
talk to me about being named in that
side initially and then what it was like
in the camp
man that came out of um
nowhere i um
i'd been to go to the gold coast with my
uh
with my girlfriend oh my wife now
and uh
i think that time while we're in the
gold coast they slowly put together like
a short list of players they were trying
to contact and
i don't think anyone could get hold of
me so i got back to new zealand uh two
days later and then they named the all
blacks and
uh i had no clue no idea what what was
uh going on until i got a message after
the team got named saying uh
congratulations so
yeah it was a little strange it just
came out of nowhere i didn't think i
played well enough to to get into the
all blacks
but um
yeah
it was a weird feeling i kind of felt
like do i deserve to be here or uh
did i play well enough but
for me it was a dream come true and uh i
didn't really worry too much about what
what i'd done to get there i just wanted
to make sure that when i get in there on
them
make it uh
make the most of the opportunity because
yeah like i've said before about the
other teams there are some
absolute legends in their team and to to
use that time to learn from them and
hopefully get back into there when i
when i ever get a chance
so you're always really confident in
your own ability
yeah i kind of always felt confident
that
once i made one team i could make a
another one and another one as long as i
just uh
didn't muck around and just make made
the most of it
but
yeah
when i got into the all blacks there's a
whole nother ball game i
you'd always uh wonder if you're good
enough to be there because it's it's the
best of the best there and um
i think i struggled at first to try and
uh
express myself or put my best foot
forward because you're always wondering
uh
am i doing the right thing or is this
do i deserve to be here
but um no in terms of uh
whenever i got the chance i didn't
really think too much about pressure i
just wanted to
get the ball in my hand or do whatever i
could to to
to put my best foot forward
and so then you'd been in all black and
then you're coming back to the blues to
make your
blues debut is that right
yeah it was it was quite crazy it's um
i kind of got um after the all black
tour and then i came back i kind of got
like the second year syndrome i uh
i played all right for the first couple
of games so then i just got injury after
injury and uh
when i when i was fit i wasn't playing
well enough and
and then missed out on the all blacks
for for a couple of years but um
uh to
play my blues they boo also
that was another blessing and another
dream come true because that was all it
was always the team i wanted to play for
um
always wanted a blue beer blues man and
to get my debut there was was awesome
but i was just kind of disappointed in
myself that i couldn't
uh back up
uh
what i'd previously done the year before
and and how i was performing with the
auckland team but uh
i guess it was a learning process for me
to
whenever whenever you make a certain
team uh that pre-season or whatever that
that time off you need to work at twice
as hard because there are other guys
that want to take your spot yeah 100 and
so you spoke a bit a little bit about
injuries there because i know you had a
fair few injuries early on in your
career like you mentioned and you you
missed out on the 2007 world cup because
of injuries
how hard was that to deal with and how
did you cope with injuries throughout
your career yeah the injuries were a bit
of a knock but i always took comfort
that a lot of my serious injuries were
when i was young
younger early 20s
so i always took comfort that i had time
uh
time on my side to be able to rehab and
then
to get my best back and yeah
um so it didn't really
it didn't really take too much of a toll
was just more of a i
cannot be as good as i was before when i
get back and that was uh
it was always a motivating factor for me
but um
no i kind of knew earlier on that i
wasn't
in the frame for that 2007 world cup so
it didn't really hit me as hard as it
would of uh
some other guys because i i'd seen the
depth that loose forward
for the all blacks at that time and uh
it was crazy so um i kind of got my head
around it uh early enough before the
team
was even uh
assembled
because i was competing with guys like
rodney soyalo sionelawaki christmas
sewing
to yoli
richie mccoy and obviously the late
jury
so yeah for me and and they were playing
awesome rugby at that time so for me
missing out on their team wasn't much of
a shock because i had nine
and i could see who was ahead of me and
and that's what i needed to work towards
and then you obviously did that work
because the following year you almost
cemented your spot into the all black
side after that yeah well it did help
that a lot of those guys had
kind of hung up their international
boots and
that did me a solid there but um it was
um it was just incredible to be accepted
back into the training camp first and
then
and then be involvement the rugby
championships or the trinations
and then uh
the rest of the end of year tours those
were those quite special and uh
i guess for me getting in there in 2008
the first challenge was to make sure
that i could stay there for as long as
possible and
was able to make a a awesome combination
with richie and rito a few years later
and
was able to
punch out a few good performances to
to keep my name there did you what a
trio
and then that obviously led you into the
2011 world cup uh talk to me about talk
to me about this experience
geez 2011 woke up uh
it all went quite fast but uh there's
one thing that sticks out for me during
out there during that uh
tournament it was just the pressure
that was on our team
[Music]
being at home and just seeing uh going
down to the viaduct and just seeing a
sea of black and everyone getting
excited about the tournament
for me i was getting excited about it
but
just uh that lingering feeling of man we
can't lose this
we can't lose here at home
and uh i think that was always uh
from the beginning to the end that that
kind of feeling
stuck with us
um
yeah so we always uh
we're always excited and
and uh looking forward to the tournament
but uh that lingering feeling is if we
go all the way we've got to make sure
that we we win this because uh
don't want to have to move
move countries and live somewhere else
did you feel that pressure when you're
out on the field or is that just leading
up to the game
no it wasn't uh
none of that pressure was uh
there on the field i would say the only
time i could feel it on the field was
probably their last 10 minutes of the
rugby world cup final
yeah that last 10 minutes just seemed to
go on forever and um
i'll give it up to the french they
played uh incredibly well they
that night and
it was uh i guess that's what added to
the to the elation to
the final whistle going off is that it
was so tight and uh we're playing in
front of our friends and families which
uh
which just uh
were just added to it all it was um it
was incredible
some night yeah and the moment when the
whole nation sort of stopped when dan
carter got injured how did that sort of
affect the team did you did you honestly
still felt feel like you guys could
still win it when you started getting
down to your fourth
choice 10.
well we didn't i didn't know we're doing
line outs on the other side of the field
so we didn't really know what was going
on until um
graeme henry blew the whistle and just
called everyone into the changing rooms
at uh
rugby league park there um and we all
went into the sheds and i think dc had
gone with the doctors and the physios by
then
and graham henry wrote the news to the
guys that uh dc has injured himself and
it's uh seems pretty serious
but uh yeah that feeling was just like
what
um
but uh yeah
i think it took us that night just to
just think over things but
we always had confidence that uh we we
could um still
still play with the players that we had
we had some awesome backups and um aaron
cruden and um slady as well
but uh when those two boys went down and
uh
and the mighty beaver came in
well yeah the boys were
uh the boys were like we still do this
but uh we just had to make sure that uh
um whoever came in and it was beaver
that at that time great to just make him
feel comfortable and
get to know his role and our patterns as
fast as possible because uh
the the final was fast approaching and
time was against us but
i've known people for a very long time
and
i think he did he'd been dreaming and
and and playing for that very moment for
a very long time so i knew he was ready
and he wouldn't let us down
but um
yeah it was definitely a interesting
couple of weeks that that
way that's so cool i love i love that
story how beaver comes in and kicks
white baiting after all the [ __ ] that
he'd cop throughout his career it was
awesome he's so cool
so how long was he in this was he only
in the side for a couple of weeks did he
have to learn all the patterns for in
like two weeks
i think it was less than
less than a couple of weeks yeah
yeah so um yeah he had to pick it up
pretty quick
but um no he did well oh yeah i think it
was less than a couple of weeks
that is impressive and a couple of
moments in that world cup that everyone
remembers about you couple of massive
tackles you just manhandled
chabal and i think digby yuani picking
them up and just throwing them around
like a ragdoll how are those tackles
because they're obviously big ones on
your highlights
man it didn't really uh didn't hurt me
until after when you're watching the
game over and and then the boys are
uh talking about it but um
yeah it was something that happened
really fast you know i don't really plan
or set out to do it like that it's just
the way it happened and
i'm glad it did because uh
the the aussies were definitely um
hitting their straps earlier on in their
game but
yeah
those kind of situations you don't
really think too much about them you
just go get out there and do them and
it's not until after you reflect and
look back at
[Music]
what you did and sometimes you
you pinch yourself and then other times
it's just like uh
you know it's just the way the team were
feeling and how we were
in the zone at that time so what was
your mindset going into a tackle because
obviously you're known for your massive
collisions your big hits
how how did you what was your sort of
mindset going into them because i'm sure
it would have been completely opposite
to mine man um
earlier on in my auckland day so i was
lucky to play for oh one of our best
nights uh good mate now sam tutupo
and um i used to always uh ask him well
what's his what does he think when he
goes into tackles because sometimes he
goes and tackles guys three times the
size and he owns them that's crazy yeah
yeah so i used to always ask him and he
had to say man just don't think about
getting hurt if you go into a tackle
thinking about getting hurt then you're
going to get hurt
you should just go on with everything
don't worry about don't think about
anything just back yourself and uh i
always took that mindset because i was
i'm a lot bigger than him and uh i see
how he just wraps guys uh
and he just falls and backwards so um i
kind of took that mindset but um yeah
and and those tackles were during the
world cup was
for me it was just trying to stop them
or
or stop any momentum they had
most of my career i tried to take
sam's mindset and not worry about uh
getting hurt not worrying about
the outcomes just getting in there and
uh
closing my eyes and
looking for the best
so how much of a tackle's technique and
how much of its mindset you reckon
i reckon uh
i reckon 60 percent mindset 40 technique
yeah
it might be more nowadays because i've
seen some of my highlights uh
from a few years back and
a lot of them will be borderline red
card nowadays
yeah
true and
at the end of that world cup you were
nominated for player of the year one of
the best players in the world at the
time how did that feel
man it was uh it was awesome was special
to be uh nominated
i felt quite lucky because majority of
our team during their world cup um they
really played well and
to be selected uh
and
a group of players
throughout the whole tournament it was
uh
it was quite a blessing um
i just felt like i fed off the majority
of the boys uh
being led by ritchie who was just the
incredible played majority of the world
cup injured
and we're still still able to
to lead the guys and then play the way
richie does um
yeah so i felt quite lucky to be
nominated amongst
some of those guys ahead of a lot of
guys in our team who i thought played
really well yeah did richie tell you
about his foot did you know about it oh
you kind of
you kind of knew about it but he
wouldn't talk about it he he'd say it's
fine
and uh
you saw him in the weights room and um
and uh
doing fitness
he'll do everything except for uh
some of the extras we do after training
he wouldn't uh he wouldn't jump or
anything just to
to make sure that but
you could see sometimes you'd be
hobbling around the hotel and um
you kind of questioned the feels all
right
but uh i was
i was too scared to go out to and ask
him about it but
he didn't like still though
oh that's classic then the move to japan
i guess so um
what was the reason behind that move man
i needed another shoulder operation
which
kind of took me out of super rugby and
uh and all blacks for at least another
year and a half
so um
for me to try and
rehab in new zealand then uh
build myself back up during the
offseason i thought why don't i just
rehab
now and then play a shorter shorter
season in japan and try and get myself
back to fitness and
and also just an experience for my young
family at that time i thought it would
be a great time to move
also a refreshener after uh that world
cup campaign which was uh was quite
mentally draining yeah
i'm sure if you ask anyone who was
involved in that it was quite a relief
afterwards it was more
not a relief of winning it was more of a
relief of not losing
yeah yeah
but uh yeah i thought it would be a good
experience for me and my young family to
go over and experience something
different while we still had the time
and
and
at that time i
was rehabbing a few injuries and had a
shoulder operation which i thought was a
perfect opportunity
and how did you find the japan league
over there
man it was quick it was um
it wasn't what i expected um they love
to run yeah
um
it was it was good experience great
great club great bunch of guys uh
i had to try and i had to work pretty
hard to get used to the speed of the
game over there the
the right contest isn't as much as it
was at super rugby which
as a bronzer flanker you have to try and
get around after the first ruck
to carry the ball and uh
not many occasions where i'd be in the
right place and
and make that right
so it was too quick
but um i was it was a great experience
and um
i would always tell these the boys about
my first captain's round where it was uh
wasn't your traditional captain's run
that you get back in new zealand it was
also full speed for an hour
and
i was just wondering how anyone would
have the energy to play a game the next
day
oh they do it definitely
yeah
they love to run
is that why you came back too much
running or was it always the plan to
come back
yeah it was always the plan to come back
i always um
i thought i'd go over there and see how
it goes and see how the experience is
and i absolutely loved the time there
and um
but uh yeah the itch was coming back to
to try and get back and play for the
blues again and hopefully put my hand up
to to make the the next world cup which
um which was always a goal of mine
which um
yeah which
that was the motivation to come back and
and give it a good go and let's talk to
me about this world cup how did this one
compare over there oh
it was um
it wasn't as stressful as the one in new
zealand yeah but uh
i guess the motivation was uh
on par we wanted to make sure that we
proved everyone wrong
everyone was saying that we couldn't win
it outside of new zealand and we
couldn't do uh back-to-back world cups
so um
like for us the motivation was already
set from uh what everyone else was
saying and we wanted to
make sure that we did something that no
other team had ever done did you always
feel confident yeah i i
yeah i was confident i knew that we had
the team to do it but um
but there's always that lingering uh
history of all like
performances outside of uh
outside of new zealand and um
also um the possibility of facing the
french and the knockout stages was
always that uh
it was that nervous
feeling and what was the final like oh
it was incredible that was intense um
that week uh just knowing that we're
coming up against our arch nemesis in
the final and uh
it was kind of similar to the feeling
that we had in um
and 211
um not wanting to let anyone down but uh
yeah in 2015 we didn't want to
lose but more importantly lose to the to
the wallabies and we woke up final
that's true was it feeling after that
game the same was it just a feeling of
relief or did this one you feel like you
could enjoy it a little bit more
yeah i i re i think it was different to
the feeling in 211
211 was more of a relief a sigh of
relief that
we didn't have to move countries and uh
215 was more of a man i can't believe we
did it yeah and uh that was more of a we
could we could really enjoy and sit back
and uh
and celebrate because we had already
known that uh five of the legends on
that on that team were going to play
their last all black game so
they added to the motivation and also we
could really enjoy it after they find a
whistle to celebrate with those guys
how good what were the celebrations like
is it always a always a big doe after a
world cup or
yeah it was quite uh
it was quite different that time the
most of the boys we went back were
staying at pentecost park and um
it wasn't anything extravagant we had
families that night and then the next
day we everyone just piled into i think
it was me and dan cole's room oh hell
that would have been would have been a
better [ __ ] in there
yeah we just piled him in honestly it
was quite tame the boys were just
sitting around playing the guitar
playing music and uh telling stories so
it wasn't uh
wasn't your usual big uh team room
team room gig um it was quite a
i think one of the guys i think aaron
smith took this uh panoramic photo of us
just piled into this one room and
as uh for me that was that would be one
of the best memories from uh
the celebrations of that that world cup
was just us just sitting back and
and enjoying the moment together
but it was um
boys
didn't want to
get too carried away because i think we
had to be at the rugby book world rugby
awards that that next night so um
yeah so there was a lot to do before we
left to come home but um yeah that
memory would stick up for me it's just
uh
being in there me and kozi's room with
uh most of the guys are sitting on the
windowsills on the floors
and just uh singing songs which was cool
that is cool and there's something that
you look back on your rugby career and
you people always think about games but
as a player you always just think about
little moments like that just yeah
something so basic this rugby world cup
that's sitting in a room yeah all the
boys just playing the guitar and just
having a yarn it's pretty crazy yeah and
it's uh being being on those come
campaigns you don't really get those uh
opportunities too often to be able to
sit back and and have a beer and just
chill out with the lads um
so yeah for me uh that that would be a
memory that sticks out
and i'll
i'll take that with me for forever
that's so cool and last thing i wanted
to mention about your rugby career was
the move to toulouse was that what was
the reason behind this move um
i kind of knew that uh i was at the end
of my tenure
with the all blacks but uh with the
blues as well i kind of
there were a lot of uh
up-and-coming players
and uh i didn't winnie i i didn't really
want to
overstay my
my welcome
so i kind of knew that i wasn't really
up for international rugby anymore and i
needed uh
i kind of still wanted to play rugby but
just i don't think that um
the playing in new zealand would
would help me or even help the
the younger players coming through so
i kind of
needed something else in
toulouse and a couple of other clubs
came
uh came knocking um i was quite
surprised that even another club came
knocking for this old man but uh
it was uh
it was something that i always wanted to
try out uh in the northern hemisphere
but i'd uh spoken to a couple of mates
who had already been to toulouse luke
mcallister corey flynn and meet a lot
so i just spoke to them what to lose was
like and they they all said positive
things about the city and the club and
and also the competition so um
yeah i thought i'd make the move over
and
and hopefully give it a good go
did you know you had as many years left
as you did because i mean you ended up
playing well into your late 30s eh
yeah no i thought it would be a one or
two year stunt to come over and uh
and probably not even play um
a starting role just to to help the next
few guys come through and and be a part
of the team but when i came over and
the the coaches were still quite
demanding of uh
how they wanted the team to play and
and uh
and the performances so for me it was
quite a surprise that uh
i came over and they didn't treat me as
if
someone that was
preparing for retirement they still
wanted me to push
the standards and push
push myself as hard as i could
and um it helped me having a few of the
boys over here already uh charlie now
joe takori and also
piraki who um
who really helped the transition
go as smooth as possible but
adding to that we had some young
up-and-coming french players and and
also some other south african players
here
who pushed the standards of the team
which uh me being an older guy you you
can't help but to try and
uh push yourself to meet those standards
which
for me it was
awesome the competitive edge gets you
yeah
you don't don't want to drag the change
and i mean the success you had last year
you got to finish your career with the
the double the champions cup and the top
14 double which i don't think many kiwis
would realize how hard that actually is
that champions cup is such a hard
tournament to win and i mean i've never
played in the top 14 but that looks like
a tough tournament as well
yeah the top 14 in itself it's uh it's
quite tough because you're playing each
uh
each team twice home and away and uh
every every game is uh
it's competitive it's uh it's physical
but then adam adam that the champions
cup games in between um
and the season gets quite long
but um
man we're we're quite lucky that uh the
boys got up for most of those knockout
games and were able to put ourselves
in reach of the final our semi-final in
a final
um
man it just all panned out the way we we
kind of uh
planned it and and wanted to work out
but
man uh
not many people get to to say they've
won a double um
with the top 14 and the europeans got
then for me being my last year i was i
was quite grateful to
to do that not many people get to finish
on their own terms
but let alone uh when when
the two
two biggest ones here in france in
europe
and what and what are the crowds like i
mean everyone talks about the french
crowds as being just next level what's
it like there in toulouse man uh crazy
here
in the south here most of the rugby
supporters are really vocal and uh
they got in numbers we're lucky last
two weeks ago was our first home game
with uh with the full crowd now
we're out with the drums and singing the
chants and um
man it's uh it's incredible and uh and
it differs to every every uh stadium and
and city you go to because they always
have their
their own songs that they sing during
the games and um
yeah some stadiums you find it hard to
to to hear yourself or even hear the
calls because they're so vocal but
i think that's one thing that sets uh
french rugby apart from most is the the
support that they get uh to most games
it's uh incredible that's awesome to see
it gets
and as a player you get so much energy
from a crowd and it i guess now that
covert sort of happened and some games
don't have crowds you can realize how
much actual intensity a crowd brings to
a game yeah man and uh
i guess
wherever you go it doesn't matter what
stadium you go to they'll have full
crowd uh most games and that definitely
adds to
to those contests and how how um how
each team um
adds to to that to that occasion and um
yeah most of the games that we play here
in top 14 has a lot of intensity just
because what the crowd bring to it how
good is that and one thing i wanted to
talk to you about is your wii side
hustle business the mint underwear one
of the great pairs of undies i've got a
few pairs myself they're on rotation
every single day
what made you decide to set this up well
we uh me and my best mates uh baon and
rocky we um i think the first lockdown
we had
went for a while and we'd always have
our whatsapp group just chatting about
um
about life and what we should do and we
we always wanted to create something
together it was just a matter of what
and
and
i think
most of us we always wanted to do
something in our community uh back at
papakura
always wanted to give back but it was
just a matter of how we could do it and
why
we went through so many ideas on what we
should do and um i think uh
rocky was the one who came out or baon
decided that uh
they struggled to find underwear
that fits perfectly for them and uh we
we chatted a few
for a few weeks and then settled on uh
why not make our own underwear for uh
all shapes and sizes and um
and uh see how it goes and and for us
it's been been awesome to be able to
create a product that uh that's all
inclusive
to all shapes and sizes but also
have um have a meaning and a movement
behind it that uh
people and and men are able to tell
their stories uh behind
their confidence in themselves or body
confidence that they've been able to
deal with
and hopefully that our our company and
our movement can add to people speaking
out about uh
their journeys or their their issues
that they've been facing throughout
their lives
love that how much of an impact how much
of a say did you have on the design of
them and stuff because it's it's pretty
cool yeah i'd say bayon bayon and rocky
would be the main uh
main uh ones in the engine room but uh
it's always
it's always been pretty hard when you're
not when all three of us are in three
different countries and yeah and uh
having to ship things all across the
world to to get feedback on it's um
it's pretty tough side i kind of because
i'm the furthest the way i kind of let
the boys
get all the materials and everything
sent to them and then i kind of trusted
what they were
what they were dealing with
it would have been a lot easier if we're
all in the same country and we're all
able to brainstorm and and and chat
about things but uh
it's the way the world is but um uh
yeah i wouldn't say too much of a say i
just kind of backed the boys
decisions and uh and went with it right
well they absolutely nailed it and
they've come to the party with a 20 off
discount too yeah
mint lads is the promo code if any
listeners out there want to try these
undies they are some of the best undies
i've worn chuck in mint lads in the
promo code and you can have 20 off it's
it's going to change your underwear draw
for sure they even smell like mantei
when you open them yeah what's what's
that we touch
i think it's bound in his little
magician daughter uh valentina i think
she's the she's the mint uh fury
that helps helps the undies smell like
mint which is a it's a good touch love
it mate you're on fire anyway mate what
a what a journey what a career we have
gone to the instagram for some questions
to finish up um awesome as you'd expect
thousands came in so um i've just chosen
a few
uh what is your world goat loose four
trio oh
that's a tough one says
i would have to i would have definitely
have to put richie in there he's uh he's
the guy you can choose yourself too by
the way
no no no no
i'll go richie
zinzan
and michael jones
oh nice yeah it's hard to get past this
yeah right there okay next question
um who was the most talented blues
teammate and why
oh
[Music]
most talented blues teammate
geez it was so much it was
i'd say someone that kind of uh
i'll say repent he doesn't thought it
might have been he was freakish
yeah he was uh he was a freak um
seeing what he was able to do on the
field but also some of the stuff that uh
wouldn't make tv that he did at
trainings
it's just
it's just freakish
um yeah i'd say he'll be the most uh x
factor but uh
that's amongst some
some other names there that i'll
i'd have to go through probably 10 or 15
other guys that uh were pretty
pretty special what was rupini like as a
trainer was he did he train hard or he
was he just freakishly gifted yeah it
was just all natural hurricane here's so
natural yeah
um
yeah he did what he had to do but uh
nothing nothing too special but um
what he was able to put out on the other
field was uh it's incredible
matt he was so good hey there was a
passage there what three maybe two or
three years where he was just
unstoppable
okay uh what's the best advice for
off-field personal development
oh what's the best advice for off-field
personal development
i reckon don't limit yourself to
anything
to reach out to as many people as
possible and uh and and
find self-improvement from everywhere
um you know i see a lot of guys these a
lot of players these days which for me i
learn from just from what they're doing
and then and what avenues are they're
learning from they're not restricting
themselves to just uh
just sports that they're looking
elsewhere from business leaders from
from other avenues to
to improve to get self-improvement so um
yeah i'll say just try and learn from as
much people and from
everywhere as possible geez that's great
advice
like that hey
okay
next one would you play for someone at
the 2023 world cup if you could if i
could i would yep 100 percent if it was
if you were eligible would you yeah
i was eligible i would
if i wasn't
a 30 year old 38 year old and a old man
so if you if they did change the rules
would you would you push for it or not
too old now
yeah i'm too old now but uh a younger me
would definitely
give it a go to be a
be a dream come true yeah what do you
reckon they needed to do with those
roles what would what do you reckon it's
the best way forward there so i reckon
they
they just need whatever
country you want to play for i just
think they need a layoff period um
will be two or three years
out of into international rugby and then
you're eligible again because uh
playing for seventh playing for a
seventh team and not playing
international rugby it's
i think that's unfair and and it doesn't
help uh
doesn't help anyone to
to exclude players who just played a few
tournaments or sevens yeah and uh not
been able to play another
for another country right that seven's
rule is an absolute joke but what do you
reckon about guys who've played for the
all blacks
and then have what three or four years
like maybe like a charles p tower etc do
you think it'd be cool to see him yeah
yeah i think if they had a layoff period
whether it was two or three years and
then uh
after that period they're they're
eligible to play for whoever they want
and i think that
for me i'd love to see that because
there's so many players who have a lot
to give to the international game and uh
they aren't able to because of the rules
and some of those pacific island nations
would be unreal if you could do that a
some of them would be
absolute world better yeah
oh interesting space anyway next one um
how much did pure sport help you keep
playing
oh man it helped uh helped a lot oh
i used to use a lot of antsy flams and
[Music]
and a few painkillers to get through the
the last few um
years of my career and um
uh finding pure sport that helped with
my knees and and also as you'd know i'm
a night owl i struggle to sleep yeah so
um i helped with inflammation in my
joints but also helped a lot with me uh
getting to sleep so you know appeal
sports been uh
been awesome and i'll definitely be
using it now that i'm all washed up and
done it's a
clear would help me get into the gym
keep the joints moving
all right good stuff okay next one uh
who was your favorite player growing up
my favorite player growing up i had a
lot i had a few um
i had christian cullen
michael jones and carlos spencer oh yeah
what a trio what was it like what was
carlos like to play with when you ended
up playing with her i was so chilled out
he's uh
cruisy but um
yeah just uh
what he what you'd see on tv when i was
growing up you'd do the same at
trainings always trying new things and
uh
but uh incredible dude so chilled out
real real crazy okay last question
what's the best piece of advice you've
received in your life
oh
that's a good one
i guess uh my mom's one that she she
used to always give me is you always
reap what you sow
so
whatever you want to get whatever you
put into things you'd always get out of
it so um yeah
you put in whatever you want to get
other things uh hard work or attention
or whatever it is like that that's very
powerful way to finish the podcast mate
you've come up trunks with a couple of
great pieces of advices but um
absolute pleasure having you on the
podcast mate what an incredible journey
um you're a all black legend like i said
at the start so
um it's been awesome to sit down and go
through your journey with you on the
water podcast thanks brother thanks for
having me
it's been awesome appreciate it bro
cheers